you've been talking about this and
expecting this for quite a long time is
this timeframe important you know what
it's it's not important it's actually
pretty known this is about the time that
they start production we think it's in
the next couple of weeks they've been
you know they've been tooling and kind
of preparing for this for the last three
or four months but now is when they
actually start production if you're
going to make 50 million 40 million
units a quarter core you have to give it
I have to have a couple months of lead
time so this is the right time frame to
start production Peter terms of your
story I know your sources aren't name so
i won't ask you to name them but i
wonder in terms of the time frame where
does this suggest a release in october
earlier you know September time friend
it's sort of a typical release schedule
for Apple you know what's new is that
this is not just a speed bump it's not
just you know fingerprint reader it's a
it's a new screen size and the larger
screen size is really one of the key
things that people want yeah we seen a
lot of successful that I noticed people
know the trainer something everyone kind
of looks over at the giant screens but
you didn't mention in your story four
inch screen you expect them to do that
as well I'm gonna go back so I we have
not been able to confirm that but i
think the assumption is that they will
they're obviously selling a whole lot of
those and would be kind of nuts to walk
away from that market entirely Brian
let's see what this is good yeah what
they're actually going to do is they're
actually we believe what we believe they
are going to keep the you know they're
going to does this 4.7 inch screen
they're going to do a five and a half
inch screen that's going to be more of
the phablet product they are going to
keep the 5s on the production line and
they're going to keep the five in the
production line but we don't believe
they continue to make the 4s anymore we
believe that product actually goes away
with this next product cycle the 4s but
the 44 inch screen as well gone the
4-inch screen the 4-inch screen is
actually what you see right now in the
five and five at the 5 and 5s so that
will remain but the older 4s which was
still on that smaller three and a half
inch screen that goes away completely Oh
got it so you know I wonder in terms of
Bill materials and what does this really
mean for the cost of the phone of the
development we know that the costs a lot
of the components tend to drop but the
glass and the battery costs maybe don't
drop as much Brian absolutely absolutely
especially the screen the screen will
definitely be more expensive but the
good thing for Apple is that a lot of
the key components
we'll still be the same and so you know
those will have declined in price over
the last year I typically think about
semiconductor price erosion at about
fifteen to twenty percent a year that
can change with volume but those are
going down but the cost of the glass
definitely more expensive particularly
on the five and a half inch one of the
big questions is well Apple charge more
for that you know we've seen this 199
299 399 pricing for a number of years
now one of the things I'm wondering is
do they raise that price of the entry
level five and a half inch in a product
whatever they end up calling it and I
think there's a great possibility of
that because of the higher price point
you don't really know about this sort of
a market for these phones I'm not just
sort of where they could sell in but
where people are in terms of contracts
we're particularly in the US the upgrade
cycle is is waiting to come next well I
mean if there's clearly just a lot of
demand for these larger phones so I
think this is a big enough change in in
the product line that a lot of people
are going to going to move up I mean in
Asia forty percent of Android phones are
of this 4.7 or larger screen size really
yeah and I think I DC's numbers are
something like you know five and five
inch in higher is expected to grow
thirty percent a year going forward
whereas slight decline in overall
smartphone growth for smaller form
factors everything Briony right and this
is a good this is a critical point here
because Samsung has been the number one
global player in mobile smartphone
volume for a number of years now and
part of that reason is because Samsung
decided to take a direction in doing
these larger screens which really seemed
kind of silly to a lot of people at the
time but it turns out this is what
consumers have really wanted for the
last several years we've seen that you
mentioned this forty percent number in
China everywhere I go in the world I see
I see people you know using the larger
screens so Apple has been kind of behind
in this regard but this is a really
critical piece of their strategy and I
think it's going to be important to
their volumes in the back half of the
year because a lot of people don't want
these smaller screen sizes so Apple is
going to see I think a big surge in
demand you know internationally because
of these nouveau these new screen sizes
and I think they're going to they're
going to topple Samsung in some of these
markets as a result because they're now
you know competing with these little
comparable screen sizes
Peter why does it take Apple so long to
make these hammond the phones it look
it's an absolute marvel in every way but
you know so is the galaxy right why does
it take Apple so much longer than
Samsung to come up with a new design to
make these kinds of changes that the
markets already responding and saying
that it was well you know i mean i think
that apple's got some sort of sacred
cows that from the Steve Jobs era I mean
honestly I mean he always was very
vociferous about the fact that that the
smaller screen size was the right size
that the portability was more important
than you know the ability to have a big
big screen you know it's kind of like
the music subscription thing that it
took them a long time to get past this
notion that people wanted to own their
music and I think that to some degree
it's a cultural thing you know I mean
they agree or some it was we saw the
same thing we saw the same thing with
the iPad as well that's a great point we
saw this anything with the iPad they
said for a while we don't believe in the
7-inch screen we think it's too big to
compete with the smartphone too small to
compete with the 10 inch iPad and then a
couple years later we saw it in the
market because they saw there was
consumer demand for it so your points
are right on i agree with you I'm
nonetheless I'm hoping we're going to
see some Samsung ads making fun of them
having made such a commitment to the
smaller phone with the particular ad
showing that the size of the hand
matching the size of the phone Brian was
there crow to be eaten here you know
what I think there is a little bit
because Apple you know Apple is
definitely being reactive in this regard
and a lot of people have expected
including myself would have expected
Apple to address this segment of the
market for a while I mean every time you
know even the note 3 which is very large
at you know that it's about 5.7 inches
they sold 10 million units of that in
the first 60 days and apples really i
think ignored that so there is a little
crow to be eaten because this is
reactive by Apple but apple doesn't
always have to move first they just have
to do it eventually in address consumer
demand and I think they're going to be
successful with this